Aloha I'm Jason Momoa and this is the
wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what does Jason Momoa
eat my favorite thing is Bolognese
what is Jason momoa's real name Joseph
Jason
my dad's name is Joe my mom didn't want
him to be a junior so in order to shut
him up she put on the birth certificate
everyone's called me Jason what do Jason
momoa's tattoos mean some of them are my
companies that I have on their own pride
of gypsies some are just personal ones
one is for someone who passed who I love
very much A lot of these are for
protection amakua which is like your
guardian these are for protection of
family and they're the ige Spears of the
head tattoo how long did that take to
get done two and a half hours and it
felt like a lifetime what happened to
Jason momoa's game of
Thrones he trusted his wife and then she
poisoned him
huh what color is Jason momoa's eyes I
want to say hazel
are they
does Jason Momoa live in Dune in the
books he does in different forms does
Duncan for real die in Dune
yeah
there's a part of him that dies
it's Jason Momoa ride a motorcycle Jason
Momoa loves motorcycles there are too
many favorites but I mean obviously
Harley's
in the late 20s I'm gonna say in the
late 20s my favorite
is Jason Momoa skateboard I might be
able to pop off a 360 kickflip grew up
skateboarding I love skateboarding I
have a half-pipe at home unfortunately
can't skateboard when I'm filming and
all I'm doing is filming
just Jason Momo climb yeah just one more
climbs he loves climbing I really love
Sport and I love bouldering bouldering
is kind of what took me around the world
now it's like I'm a professional Spotter
and Belair for my children who climb
harder than me which is a dream come
true I'm probably the heaviest climber
in the world I'm 260 pounds
these fingers hurt in fact I have a show
coming out called The Climb which can be
on HBO Max and it's coming out soon is
Jason Momoa
brush his hair I don't don't touch it
leave it alone use your fingers
scratch your head pull your hair that's
it
how long has Jason Momoa been acting
2019 so 43 now a long time I did not
want to be an actor I was in the right
place at the wrong time my family is all
in stunts and so I was in Hawaii a TV
show came and I just got lucky and then
I fell in love with acting and I fell in
love with the idea that I could
play characters like Flip or Drogo or
Aquaman so it kind of found me how to
grow Jason Momoa beard
just let the beard grow how to be like
Jason Momoa be kind
be nice
because everyone is going through [ __ ]
how much does Jason Momoa
lift not a lot I do not like lifting and
now that I'm getting older I try not to
lift that much I just do stuff to make
it where my heart is better no more how
much do you [ __ ]
how much do you squat nothing
what
we used to chase a Momoa what do I
listen to
I listen to Everything I mean I listen
to Tom Waits only DeFranco to God Speedy
black hamburger to Cindy Lauper to
[ __ ] Eminem everything what is Jason
momoa's next project I'm working on
chief of War a massive epic story about
the Hawaiian islands and my movie
Slumberland is coming out November 18th
which is my first comedy it's actually
my only movie that's kind of for the
whole family it just touches on a lot of
beautiful subjects grief and love and
loss and You're gonna laugh you're gonna
cry
your character it's kind of like my
spirit animal He's Got Claws he's got a
pink velvet coat he's got a top hat he's
got horns fangs and he's a forever a 12
year old
flip
who is Jason almost done double I first
started out with Glenn Ennis because I
have to give props to my homie glennonis
who was with me for the Stargate
Atlantis Kim farty is my main stunt man
he travels with me now and then Ryan
Taran he did Slumberland with me
actually in Slumberland I ripped my arm
and see so I didn't have I can use my
right arm said everything in Slumberland
I'm using my left hand even when I throw
the Pearl at the end while Kim was
getting everything ready for Aquaman
Ryan was helping me with c and with
Slumberland so Ryan I love you Kim I
love you forever love you guys what did
Jason Momoa
get a scar
it was an accident
well Jason Momoa be in Fast and Furious
10 I will be and boy do you got a
surprise coming to you
slumberland's like my favorite movie
I've ever been on it's gonna be great
for sound but fast
what I doing fast
you guys got no idea
it is awesome I gotta play the villain
it's about goddamn time
can Jason Momoa swim everything hate
swimming is that true I don't hate
swimming I don't like running but I can
do it yeah
yeah I swim I don't know I think I'm
just dense so I sink
can Jason Momoa CNC
yes I can see and see
can Jason Momoa draw no not very good at
it
no no so that's just Wikipedia where
someone reads an interview and they just
like set everything and like you do this
I was uh looking at a Monet and did some
pastels and I was like oh this is nice
it was fun I didn't study pastels
but I love pastel colors
can Jason Momoa sing absolutely not
nope not at all
finally
where's Jason Momoa buy his Rings ah I
love handcrafted things so on Instagram
you gotta find people like in their back
shops working and I don't know how to
make this stuff but I love watching and
I love learning I'm just a fan of
handcrafted artisans
where to buy Jason momoa's water you can
get up and get on Amazon's and Hawaii we
have it at Foodland right now which is
awesome where is Jason momoa's
foreign
I just remembered this it is a game
that I did
a long time ago and it was just being
silly I'm hitting on this woman Brittany
Daniels played the role and walking into
this football game and I'm Just Being
Cheesy he's just a total cheese ball he
like takes his chair and he like just
flicks it out and then he sits on it
next to her and puts his arm around her
and he's a tool so
[Music]
wired had a great time and yes I would
do it again
[Music]